hello everyone welcome back to new
people today we welcome
Vladimir shoo ha cheap brain at the
European Commission joint research
center lady Mia will teachers that
science and politics can have good
chemistry we will also explore vladimir
past student life in czechoslovakia and
of course we will test his knowledge in
a science quiz so are you ready to
embark on this experiment then let's
begin
[Music]
I am pleased to welcome let me assure ha
the man who knows how to match a suit
with a lab coat Vladimir is the chief of
the joint research center this is the
service of the European Commission
providing scientific expertise to help
make policymaking policy and science is
it a good match let's try to see that
with our guests
good morning gardenia hello lady a
simple question to start with are you a
scientist or are you policy maker I
think that I'm boat and I even may say
that I feel at the same time as
entrepreneur and imprint apprentice
because I'm learning everyday from my
wonderful colleagues and I'm putting
together the Datsun and I hope I can
bring some innovation to what we do
could you tell us in simple words was
what joint research centre is about well
it's quite straightforward we want to
make our decision in the best possible
way and if you want to do this in the
best possible way if you need to have a
knowledge behind that decision so we are
trying to provide that knowledge so we
may say we are scientific and knowledge
service of European Commission some may
say that policymaking is about politics
after all so why do we need science as
we say policymaking is a combination of
three things politics obviously values
and facts so then what we are trying to
provide is to provide the facts and also
even more now in this period we are
trying to provide better understanding
of values of the society because this is
something which is quite an important
element more and more nowadays I have
some concrete examples and I would like
you to tell me where science is making
the difference where the G is GRC made
the difference
so first food safety in European Union
we may proudly say that we are from the
food point of view the safest place on
this planet and this is largely because
we use scientific knowledge
on the pin and the legislation policy
rules regulation which is linked to this
and and we are at the heart of it so in
you can tell example you have you know
this is something what we consume and
this is in contact with something which
contains this so that what we do and you
have you have different types of
containers sometimes if it is can it
stays for one year two years five years
so then we provide the methodology how
to test if the container is really good
if the container is not releasing
harmful harmful substances to to the
food or two beverages drinks etc so this
is just one example and other topic
forest fires you know that this summer
there were lots of forest fires in
Sweden and Greece how is the GRC helping
well obviously forest fires but not only
forest fires all natural disasters it's
it's one of the core businesses so of
the JC we are running European drought
observatory we are running forest fire
observatory so then we are helping
authorities in in member states to see
and for see if there is a risk and what
is the level of the risk of the fires in
in their own country so this is
something which is available for every
every citizens of Europe are there any
Maps you're providing the maps which are
updated on the daily basis but we are
also providing the forecasts another
topic rare disease oh we always do
things where there is a clear added
value because we don't want to act as
3000 and first the university or
Research Institute of European Union so
then always we step in if there is
nobody else who can do it and this is
exactly a good example that for the rare
diseases if you look at the global scale
at the European Union level they are not
that rare so they are quite numerous but
at the level of individual countries
they are rare so you have maybe one two
three cases so here we are coming with a
European perspective so then we are
putting together different elements and
you know obviously out of 500 millions
so you can you can detect some patterns
and be much more useful for diagnosis
and treatment Vladimir I would like that
we go back in time who was led in your
shoe ha 30 years ago Oh 30 years ago not
many people remember because it seems
that people have a very short memory but
I still remember quite well that I
remember very well the queues for banana
and whatever we wanted
and obviously the freedom of speech
freedom of movement and was just an
illusion well we have been dreaming
about that life
freedom new society well it's it's bit
symbolic that you know when I was at the
university universities at the bank of
the Danube in Bratislava and just across
the Danube there was a hill of Austria
and so we saw the hill but we could not
get to this hill and so I think that
that was a very symbolic moment to see
this cleavage this barrier and obviously
inside inside the country now if you
don't remember that much you were very
active in student movement and you'd
organize those summer camps we're gonna
see some some pictures what what did you
want to achieve my friends we have
always been reflecting you know what we
as a more or less power less students we
can do and I was convinced at that time
and I'm convinced till now that
everybody has certain a capacity to act
react and do something in in its own
capacity we thought we cannot change the
country but we can try to change at
least little bit of environment to
create the space of of the freedom space
of free thinking at least for a certain
period of time and it was also triggered
by by these ignorance of the government
and and the
the ruling party towards heritage the
country was not very rich and they
simply didn't care because it was passed
which was different and the communism
ideology this picture of you you're
among you're in this crowd on a train
what is this yeah that was the first
that was the first idea which was
developed by our good friends and they
they saw these I would say technical
heritage this old railway which was
working in the forest and it was about
to be totally demolished so then so that
the first camp started there I
remembered that many many friends very
even hiding different parts and pieces
of the Train of the right way just to
preserve it for for the future I think
that train was saved and still it works
until today there is a museum there is
an open-air museum and there is a 11
kilometers of this river is saved and it
it serves for tourists and then there
was the Velvet Revolution so what were
you doing at that moment I can proudly
say that many graduates of this of the
summer camps became very active in this
in this Velvet Revolution it was all
triggered by by this the Prague
demonstration on 17 of November which is
international student day and and then
it spread all over the country at that
time I was already graduated from
University and I was working at the
Academy of Sciences anthem and I became
in my Institute of the president of the
after the the the committee which was
changing which was at the lead of of the
change I was quite young and I think
that it was not because of my capacities
but because of the others being maybe
too afraid so they somehow pushed me
here forward so that was that was nice
we had
in different Institute's they had the
different cells of the Communist Party
and my role was to dissolve the cell in
our Institute so then I had to convince
all those because it was velvet so it
was not bloody so I had to convince them
to sign the dismissal and dissolution of
the of the cell of the Communist Party
[Music]
let me there is another part of your
life that we that'll like to discuss
it's your active involvement with the
Roma community can you tell us a bit
more about it the Roma community is one
of the few if not the only big community
in European Union living in in the
conditions which we call
intergenerational or generational
poverty that means that you are
inheriting poverty from your parents and
they inherited the poverty from their
grandparents so then all these patterns
of behaviors are repeating our and their
poverty and this behavior is is in a way
embedded in a way in their psychological
DNA so that means that they are unable
to act and react as a majority good some
some pictures of you and I would like
you to explain me exactly what you are
doing this is how I'm starting or ending
my holidays every year so then I'm
spending a few days and organizing few
games a bit important education is a
great great fun yes my speciality is a
night game that everybody is scared and
then we make them going to the forest or
to the old buildings abundance sharing
it's a purse carry but they will
remember for the rest of their life and
it ends always in a nice way with some
chocolate or with some nice nice places
what should I do if I want to get
involved what can I do what can the EU
do to help a Roma inclusion well I think
that there are two dimensions you and
you these are two different things
I think that I will stay with you
because I think that this is mostly
interpersonal relation which is the most
important because this is what they do
not have it's not about money
obviously money helps legal framework
helps many things are useful but just to
reach the full integration we need to
have personal engagement personal
sponsorship friendship redeem you thank
you very much for all this answers I
have a last game for you and about you
know it recognized we've all I don't
know what is the game but I this I
recognize the periodic table the
periodic table of elements the special
one you want but that's for another game
it's for another video that you can
watch here for the rest thank you very
much for watching you can share comments
and I really much look forward to seeing
you again in another episode
[Music]
you